Speaker 1: Donald Trump jr has now attacked me
and unleashed a hate mob against me. Candace owens
is in on it. The blaze infowars. How far is this
going to go? All because of a tweet that I since
deleted. Which all of you understood perfectly.
I had tweeted about the shooting in Nashville.
Tongue in cheek, of course, not literally blaming
the victims of the shooting. Something I would
never do that. It's surprising that there
would be a shooting at a Christian school,
given that it's a Christian school. And they pray
every single one of you in my audience understood
the point of the tweet. Thoughts and prayers don't
prevent mass shootings, but right wingers, people
who don't know me. All sorts of different folks
looking to contrive controversy and send hate
my way are saying. But David, you're blaming the
victims. You're blaming children. Of course I'm
not. And in fact, after deleting the tweet because
of the number of threats that rained down upon me,
I put out a video, a video where I said my tweet
angered about a million people and I explained the
entire thing. And of course, that video has almost
100% likes and it has you, my viewers, who say,
David, there's not even a controversy here. It's
insane that they even turned this into something.
But they did. And now this represents the greatest
existential threat to The David Pakman Show that
we have ever faced. That is not an exaggeration.
They are going after our advertisers, even though
they claim to be against that tactic. They are
making threats not only to me but to others in
my circles. I won't even do details because I
might just encourage them more. The situation
has reached a fever pitch. Don Junior tweeting
yesterday, Imagine being this big of a P.O.S. to
his nearly 10 million followers. Unfortunately,
this is what many on the left think of you. If
you have traditional American views and don't
follow blindly and capitulate to their every
lunatic whim. Truly evil at this point. Of
course, if by traditional American views,
Don Jr means doing nothing. About mass shootings,
which is exactly what he and his father,
his administration did and want to do. Then, yeah,
that's not for me. And of course, then the hate
mob descended. And it wasn't just Don Jr. Candace
Owens devoted a segment on her show to this where
she was almost in tears over my tweet, posting
to Twitter, quote, More left wing filth. David
Pakman is laughing at the fact that the dead
children are Christians who believe in prayer.
These are real tweets. These people think it's
funny when Christian children die. No, I think
it's tragic when thoughts and prayers are the
only thing offered by Republican officials. And
she is even going after our advertisers. And this
is where this is getting genuinely bad. I wish it
wasn't, but it is. Candace Owens, adding to any
of your advertisers who may be following this,
this is not a contrived mob or anti-Semitism. This
is you dealing with the consequences of sending
the most horrifically bigoted tweet directed at
dead Christian children who, according to you,
should have prayed harder. Of course, that's not
the point. The point is thoughts and prayers don't
work. Who wants to actually do something about
the scourge of God of gun violence? And yes,
it's a scorch. That's how Trump says it. And now I
say it the same way. Donald Trump's former lawyer,
Jenna Ellis, getting in on it. This is a
horrific take that the author didn't walk back,
just said he's now getting harassed, so deleted
it David Pakman you harassed Christians and should
apologize for this offensive tweet targeting our
sincere faith. No, I'm targeting anyone who says
thoughts and prayers and nothing else. Jenna Ellis
says evil persists and we don't represent. Prayer
is a complete shield to the perils of the fallen
world. But rather than through faith in Christ, we
can accept salvation and live it. I mean, it just,
you know, religious babble. Now Thessalonians
tells us, Give me a break. The right wing blaze
writing an article about this, They weren't
praying enough. Progressive radio host goes viral
over vile reaction to Christian school massacre.
Thoughts and prayers Don't start mass shootings.
That's the point. Infowars. Is it possible
they weren't praying enough? David Pakman mocks
Christians murdered by trans shooter in Nashville
and the longest man in the world on the pandemic.
Alex Berenson also tweeting, Just apologize, David
Pakman. You are shameful, not just for what you
said. Did you think it was funny? Blaming kids for
their own deaths is beyond awful because in your
non-apology you then blamed anti-Semitism for the
response. Blame yourself, not your religion. Not
blaming my religion, but you should see thousands,
thousands of anti-Semitic messages. Jew the k-word
ovens, people suggesting they're going to come and
do this, that the other thing too this and that
the other person I'm not even going I don't I
don't even want to put it out there because it's
a deluge where security has been contracted and so
on and so over it. You have no idea what's going
on. It's wild. It is wild. So they are sending the
hate mob against us and we now have to see whether
we can weather this storm. Most of you reached out
with support. It's been great hearing from, you
know, the one upside when these things happen
is the messages from people who have been in
the audience for a long time. And I got so many
messages from people saying, David, none of these
people are in your audience. We all know what you
meant. Thoughts and prayers do nothing. We've
got to do something about gun violence. You're a
father. You're frustrated. It's disgusting what's
going on. Don't even worry about it. It'll pass.
It'll pass. I heard from I guess I shouldn't
even say. But many of the people you know,
in our circle who do shows like mine,
they reached out to me privately and said,
This is really bad. These are people who don't
know anything about you. They don't follow the
show. They have seized on to something to take
attention away from the fact that they have
nothing to offer to actually stop the shootings.
So we are getting crushed right now. And the best
thing you can do is leave a comment, leave
a like. Try to push back against this mob,
which remember, isn't even in our audience. And
of course if you can get a membership at join
Pacman dot com. Please do we have the coupon
code cancel cancel cancel the cancellation
that they are trying to do. Let me now talk
more about what it is they are trying to do.